We're never going to stop exploring the unknown in air and space.
We're not going to stop innovating for the benefit of humanity...
...and inspiring the world through discovery.
'22 will go down in the history books as one of the most accomplished years...
...all of NASA's history and missions,...
...the golden age of space exploration.
There was a philosopher, a historian,...
...someone who had a great grasp of the future named Carl Sagan, a scientist,...
...and he said, "Exploration is in our nature.
We began as wanderers, and we are wanderers still.
We have lingered long enough on the shores of the cosmic ocean.
We are ready at last to set sail for the stars."
We have set sail for the stars.
Now we're going to reach out to the unreachable stars.